منذ بدايه شهر رمضان هناك العديد من
الفضاءات هنا في الجزائر العاصمه التي
تبرمج سهرات فنيه تراثيه هذا المعلم مسرح
محي الدين بشطارزي الذي نظم منذ بدايه
الشهر حفلات او سهرات للمسرح المحترف
والهاوي وكذا مسرح الطفل وايضا حفلات
للغناء الليله هناك برنامج
لمغني الشعبي الشهير الشيخ عبد القادر
شاعر
في البهو الرئيسي
لمسرح محي الدين بشتارزي هناك العديد من
العائلات الجزائريه التي قدمت الى هنا في
انتظار فتح البوابات الرئيسيه لدخول
قاعه المسرح ومتابعه عبد القادر الشاعو
مغني الشعبي
ونعرفه
هذه هي القاعه الرئيسيه
لمسرح محي الدين سنحاول ان نكلم السيد
قرمي جمال والمدير الفني للمسرح الوطني
الجزائري عن برنامج شهر رمضان سيد قرمي
سؤالي انتم خصصتم عده سهرات رمضانيه في
شهر رمضان الكريم كيف كان اختيار هذه
السهرات منذ اليوم الاول لشهر رمضان قبل
كل شيء رمضان كريم لكل الامه الاسلاميه
عامه والجزائر خاصه حقيقه
المسرح الوطني الجزائري اراد في كل شهر
رمضان ان البرنامج هو يتماشى مع روح
رمضانيه من خلال تسطير برامج عده يعني
منها مسرحيات التي تخاطب المجتمع الجزائري
في بيئته وكذا حتى الحفلات
الشعبيه الاندلسيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
منذ بدايه رمضان هناك اقبال كبير من
العائلات الجزائريه على السهرات التي تقام
هنا في هذا المسرح برايك امين ما الذي
يجلب العائله الجزائريه لهذا النوع من
الاغاني التراثيه او من الحفلات التراثيه
اصاله اصاله الموسيقى
وعتقتها هي التي تعطي هذا الزخم وهذا
الاقبال الجماهيري الكبير لهذا النوع
الموسيقي نحكيو على الشعب الاندلسي
المالوف طبعا العائله الجزائريه تحس بالبد
وء بالالوان
[موسيقى]
الموسيقي
وانا عشقي
[موسيقى]
يا ربي كمله
السهرات الرمضانيه على وقع اغنيه الشعب
ليست فقط داخل القاعات في مسرح محي الدين
بشتارزي خلفنا هنا في قلب ساحه بورسعيد
يتجمع كثير من الشباب للاستمتاع بهذه
الوصلات الغنائيه لاغنيه الشعب في قلب هذه
الساحه التاريخيه معنا السيد محمد وهو
مسؤول في مؤسسه فنون وثقافه لولايه
الجزائر سيد محمد تنظمون مثل هذه الحفلات
ليليا لاغنيه الشعب ما هو برنامجكم وما هي
الرساله من خلال هذه الحفلات الشعبيه يدخل
في اطار البرنامج الذي ولايه الجزائر
يسمى بتنشيط مدينه الجزائر حيث ارتات مؤسف
منطقه
برنامج على
يخص السهرات الفنيه
[موسيقى]